こんしゅうのざっくばらん
Emergence（創発・発現）について
エーアイ関連の論文を読んでいると、"Emergence" という言葉がしばしば出てきます。
日本語では「創発」と訳すのがいっぱん的ですが、私は「発現」の方が良いと思っています。
「創発」は、もともと複雑系科学の分野で定着した訳語です。
個々の部分の性質からは予測できない性質が、全体として立ち現れることを指します。
アリ一匹の行動をいくら調べても、コロニー全体が見せる秩序は説明できない、というあれです。
訳語としては正確なのですが、いかんせん日常語からの距離が遠く、この言葉を見た瞬間に読者の理解が止まってしまう。
いっぽう、エーアイの文脈で起きていることは、もう少し素朴です。
それまで隠れていた能力が、あるところから表に出てくる。
水中に潜っていた人が水面に顔を出すことを英語では "emerge" と表現しますが、まさにそのイメージです。
だから私は「発現」の方が実感に近いと思うのです。
「発現」は、生物学では「遺伝子発現」のように使われる言葉でもあります。
持っていなかったものが新しく生まれるのではなく、もともとそこにあったものが、条件が整って表に出てくる。
この語感が、エーアイで起きていることにもちょうど重なるのです。
誰も教えていない能力が、現れる
Emergenceとは、ニューラルネットに十分な量のデータを与えて学習させた結果、誰も明示的には教えていない能力が、その内部に現れてくることを指します。
教えたわけではないのに、できるようになっている。
ここが肝心なところです。
一番分かりやすい例を見てみましょう。
ニューラルネットに、足し算の問題と解答を大量に与えて学習させることを考えます。
学習が不十分なうちは、学習データとして与えた問題には答えられても、見たことのない問題には答えられません。
単に問題と解答のセットを丸暗記しているだけだからです。
ところが、ニューラルネットのパラメータを増やし、同時に学習するデータ量を増やしていくと、学習データとして見たことのない問題まで解けるようになります。
個々の問題と答えを丸暗記するのではなく、誰も明示的には教えていない「足し算の法則」に相当するものを内部で獲得し、それを使って未知の問題を解いている。
これは「汎化（generalization）」と呼ばれる現象です。
そして、モデルの規模や学習量を増やしていく中で、それまで見えなかった汎化能力があるところから顕著に現れるなら、それがEmergenceとして観察されます。
なお、エーアイの学界では、Emergenceを「モデルのきぼを上げていくと、あるきぼを境に突然できるようになる能力」という狭い意味で使うこともあります。
しかしここではもう少し広く、「誰も明示的には教えていない能力が、データからニューラルネットの中に現れてくること」全般を指して使います。
きぼを上げた瞬間に跳ね上がるかどうかよりも、「人間が書いていないものが、いつの間にかそこにある」ことの方が、はるかに重要だと思うからです。
ルールを書く時代の終わり
ニューラルネットにこんな能力があることが広く知られるいぜんは、人間がその手の法則や特徴を一つずつ教えるアプローチが採用されていました。
例えば「猫」を画像から認識させる場合、「4本足である」「耳が尖っている」「目が正面に二つ付いている」「瞳孔が縦長である」といった、猫を識別するために役立ちそうな特徴を人間が考え、それをコンピュータに与えていたのです。
しかし、この方法にはすぐ限界が来ます。
「4本足で耳が尖っている」だけでは、シェパードと区別がつきません。
では何を足せばいいのか。
人間が言語化できる特徴の組み合わせで、猫と猫でないものの境界を引き切ることは、驚くほど難しいのです。
2012年に登場したAlexNetというニューラルネットは、この作業が不要であることを決定的に示しました。
大量の画像と正解ラベルを与えることによって、「耳の形」「輪郭」「毛並み」といった認識に必要な特徴そのものをニューラルネットの内部で学習させ、高い画像認識能力を実現したのです。
人間が一つも指定していない特徴表現が、データから現れた。
そして現代のエーアイは、この延長線上にあります。
言語モデルが例をいくつか見せられただけで新しい課題をこなす「文脈内学習」もそうです。
もう一つ面白いのが、オセロの棋譜だけを延々と学習させたモデルの研究です。
「盤面」というものを一度も教えていないのに、モデルの内部を調べてみると、今の盤面の状態に対応する構造ができあがっていた。
「世界モデル」と呼ばれるこの研究も、誰も設計していないものがデータから現れたという点では、まったく同じ現象です。
同じ転換が、自動運転にも
初期のTesla FSDでは、カメラの映像からニューラルネットが車線、歩行者、自動車、信号などを認識し、その情報を受け取った人間が書いたソフトウェアが、「障害物を避ける」「交通ルールに従う」「この場合には車線変更する」といった判断をしていました。
しかしV12以降、Teslaはこのアプローチを大きく変えました。
人間が個々の運転ルールをプログラムするのではなく、大量の実際の運転データを与え、運転に必要な振る舞いそのものをニューラルネットに学習させる方向へと転換したのです。
直感的には、「障害物を避ける」「交通ルールに従う」といったルールを明示的に与えた方が良いように感じます。
しかし現実の道路には、工事現場、停留所に停まったバス、横断歩道に立っているのに道を渡らない人、ボールを追いかけて飛び出してくる子供、反対車線から暴走してくる車と、ありとあらゆる状況があります。
そのすべてを前もって想定し、「この場合にはこうする」と人間が書き切ることは、事実上不可能です。
FSDでも「発現」は起きている
そして興味深いことに、Teslaで自動運転ソフトウェアのかいはつを率いる技術者たち自身が、V12以降のFSDについて「誰も教えていない振る舞いが現れる」と語っています。
特定の状況への対処を明示的に学習させたわけではないのに、車がそれらしく振る舞う。
ルールを書いていた頃には、基本的には人間が記述したルールの範囲内でしか振る舞えませんでした。
書いていないことが起きるというのは、それ自体が新しい事態なのです。
もちろん、その振る舞いの種は、学習に使った人間の運転データの中にあったはずです。
しかし、それを「こういう場面ではこうする」と切り出してコードに書いた人間は、どこにもいない。
開発者本人が、自分の作ったシステムに対して「教えていないことをやっている」と言うようになった。
まさにEmergenceです。
「突然」ではない、という反論
ちなみに、このEmergenceについては、「あれは幻だったのではないか」という有名な反論があります。
能力があるきぼを境に突然立ち上がるように見えるのは、「完全に正解したかどうか」といった白黒の尺度で測っているからであって、もっと細かい尺度で測れば、能力はなだらかに伸び続けている、という指摘です。
私は、この指摘は正しいと思います。
そして、だからこそ「発現」なのだとも思うのです。
何もないところから突然能力が生まれるのではなく、水面下ではずっと何かが育っていて、あるときそれが私たちの目に見える形で顔を出す。
「創発」という言葉が持つ「無から立ち現れる」という響きよりも、こちらの方が、実際に起きていることにはずっと忠実なのです。
現代エーアイの本質
現代のエーアイの本質は、人間がすべてのルールを書くことではなく、十分なデータと計算資源を与えることによって、必要なルールや能力をニューラルネットの中に「発現」させることにあります。
猫を見分ける特徴も、足し算の法則も、路上での振る舞いも、人間が書いたものではありません。
水面下で何かが育ち、あるとき顔を出す――この光景を、私たちは今、あらゆる領域で繰り返し目撃しているのです。
【参考資料】
[EN]CVPR 2026 DriveX Workshop Keynote 7 Phil Duan (Tesla) - Self-Driving at Scale with Foundation Models[/EN]
[EN]ImageNet Classification with Deep Convolutional Neural Networks[/EN]
― AlexNetの論文（2012年）
[EN]Grokking: Generalization Beyond Overfitting on Small Algorithmic Datasets[/EN]
― 丸暗記から突然汎化に切り替わる現象の研究
[EN]Emergent Abilities of Large Language Models[/EN]
― 狭い意味でのEmergenceを広めた論文
[EN]Are Emergent Abilities of Large Language Models a Mirage?[/EN]
― 「あれは幻ではないか」という反論
[EN]Emergent World Representations: Exploring a Sequence Model Trained on a Synthetic Task[/EN]
― オセロの棋譜だけを学習させたモデルの内部に盤面が現れた研究
エーアイビジネス・レイヤー
せんしゅう、StripeがOpenRouterを買収したことを紹介しましたが、それに続いて、今度はエヌビディアをめぐる大きなニュースが二つ続きました。
一つは、Poolsideというエーアイモデルの開発企業に出資すると同時に技術をライセンスし、100人以上のエンジニアを引き抜いたこと（買収ではありません）。
もう一つは、Hugging Faceを百二十九億ドルで買収したこと(
[EN]Nvidia Agrees to Buy Open Source Model Repository Hugging Face For $12.9 Billion[/EN]
)です。
一見バラバラに見えるこれらの動きも、全体像を持たないまま個別に眺めていると、何が起こっているのかが見えてきません。
そこで一度、エーアイビジネスを以下のようなレイヤーに分けて整理してみましょう。
データセンター
（建物、電力、水）
半導体
: エヌビディア、AMDなど
計算資源の卸売
[EN]: AWS、Microsoft、Googleなど[/EN]
エーアイモデルの製造
[EN]: OpenAI、Anthropic、Poolsideなど[/EN]
モデルの流通
[EN]: Hugging Faceなど[/EN]
すいろんの提供
[EN]: Together、Groqなど[/EN]
経路と課金
: OpenRouterなど
アプリケーション
[EN]: Perplexity、Cursorなど[/EN]
これだけでも十分に複雑ですが、さらに分かりにくくしているのが、複数のレイヤーにまたがってビジネスをする企業が何社も存在するという点です。
[EN]Google: 1, 2, 3, 4, 6, 8[/EN]
[EN]Microsoft: 1, 2, 3, 4, 6, 8[/EN]
エヌビディア: 2（＋出資や技術ライセンスを通じて 3 と 4 に深く関与）
SpaceX+xAI: 1, 4, 6, 8（計算資源は自社向け）
[EN]OpenAI: 1, 4, 6, 8[/EN]
[EN]Anthropic: 4, 6, 8[/EN]
冒頭のエヌビディアとPoolsideの話は、まさにこの「またがり」の一例です。
半導体（2）で圧倒的な地位を築いたエヌビディアが、自社のジーピーユーを最もじょうずに使いこなすモデル製造（4）にまで手を伸ばそうとしている、と読むことができます。
そして「買収ではありません」という点も重要です。
企業を丸ごと買うのではなく、技術のライセンスを受けた上で主要なエンジニアだけを迎え入れるという形は、マイクロソフトによる Inflection、グーグルによる Character.エーアイ、メタによる Scale エーアイ と同じ手法で、独占禁止法上の審査を回避しながら、実質的には買収と同じ果実を手に入れるやり方です。
この形が繰り返し使われているという事実そのものが、モデル製造レイヤー（4）の単独での生き残りがいかに難しいかを物語っています。
レイヤーごとに、経済性はまったく違う
ビジネスの規模や競争の度合いは、レイヤーによって大きく異なります。
せつびとうしに最もお金がかかるのが3で、ここはハイパー・スケーラーと呼ばれるIT大手と、ネオクラウドと呼ばれる事業者数社によって提供されています。
この3が、1と2の顧客にあたります。
資本集約的で、減価償却が重くのしかかるレイヤーです。
2の半導体ビジネスは、巨額の研究開発費を必要としますが、粗利益率が非常に高いビジネスなので、スケールさえすれば大きな利益を上げることができます。
現時点で、このエーアイブームで最も確実に儲かっているレイヤーです。
4のモデルの製造ビジネスは、最先端を走り続けるためには（モデルの学習プロセスのために）莫大な投資が必要で、それを回収する場所が6と8になります。
しかし推論プロセスにも計算資源が必要で、それは3から買わなければならないため、必ずしも高い粗利益率で稼げる保証はありません。
学習で先行しても、その優位が数ヶ月で追いつかれてしまうという構造的な問題も抱えています。
6のすいろんの提供は、ハイパー・スケーラー（3の会社群）も自社クラウド上で同じサービスを提供しているため、専業事業者にとっては最初から巨人と隣り合わせのしじょうです。
ユニークなのは5と7
この中で特にユニークなのが、5と7です。
5ではHugging Faceが、7ではOpenRouterが、それぞれ非常に強いポジションを確立してデファクト・スタンダードになっています。
面白いのは、この二つがどちらも、隣接するレイヤーをコモディティ化する圧力として働いている点です。
Hugging Face（5）は、世界中のオープン・モデルを誰でもすぐに手に入る状態に置きました。
これはクローズドなモデルを直接流通させるわけではありませんが、「無料で手に入る十分に良いモデル」が常に選択肢として存在する状態を作り出し、モデル製造（4）の価格に絶えず下方圧力をかけています。
OpenRouter（7）は、多数の推論サービスを一つのエーピーアイと一つの請求書の裏側に隠してしまいました。
利用者から見れば、どの事業者のすいろんを使っているかはもはや意識されず、価格と速度だけで自動的に選ばれる。
これは推論サービス（6）にとって、極めて厳しいコモディティ化の圧力です。
そう考えると、StripeがOpenRouterを買収した理由も見えてきます。
7は、上のレイヤーにも下のレイヤーにも属さない「通り道と課金」のレイヤーであり、そこを押さえるということは、エーアイの利用そのものが流れる決済のパイプを押さえるということです。
決済の巨人がそこに張った、と読むべき動きでしょう。
エヌビディアがHugging Faceを買収するのも、5というレイヤーが持つ同じ種類の「位置の価値」を手に入れたがっているからです。
オープンエーアイとアンソロピックが直面するもの
上場が取り沙汰されているオープンエーアイとアンソロピックは、確かに大きく売り上げを伸ばしています。
しかし彼らのビジネスは、モデル側では（Hugging Faceを通じて流通する）オープン・モデルとの戦いに、推論サービス側ではOpenRouterがもたらす価格競争に晒され続けます。
上下から挟まれた4というレイヤーで、中長期的に利益を上げ続けることができるかどうかは、まだ分かりません。
彼らがアプリケーション（8）に力を入れ、さらにオープンエーアイがデータセンター（1）にまで降りていこうとしているのは、この構造を彼ら自身がよく理解しているからだと、私は見ています。
【参考資料】
[EN]Stripe agrees to acquire OpenRouter to help businesses optimize token routing and usage[/EN]
[EN]― Stripe Newsroom[/EN]
[EN]Nvidia pays Poolside $6bn to license its model factory and hire 109 staff[/EN]
― The Next Web
[EN]Hugging Face reportedly in talks to be acquired for $13B[/EN]
― TechCrunch
[EN]OpenAI & Anthropic IPO: What's Confirmed, What's Still Speculation[/EN]
― Barchart
[EN]OpenAI, Oracle, and SoftBank expand Stargate with five new AI data center sites[/EN]
― オープンエーアイ
HOT CHIPS 2026
せんしゅう、「
」というカンファレンスが、Stanford UniversityのMemorial Auditoriumで開催されました。
1989年から続く、シーピーユー/ジーピーユー/エーアイアクセラレータなどの「中身」を設計者自身がかなり技術的に説明するカンファレンスです。
ことしのプログラムは本当に盛りだくさんでしたが、その中で目に留めるべき価値があったものを紹介します。
[EN]Jalapeno's first results show industry-leading speed and efficiency in AI inference[/EN]
オープンエーアイがBroadcomと共同かいはつした推論専用チップ「Jalapeno（ハラペーニョ）」の初めての性能測定結果を公表し、オープンエーアイのベンチマークでは、エヌビディアのGB200/GB300システムを電力効率と応答速度の両面で上回った、と主張する発表です。
エーアイサービスの原価構造を左右する話なので紹介します。
公表された数字は、エヌビディアのGB200およびGB300ラックシステムとの比較で、電力1キロワットあたりの処理量が1.5〜1.9倍、利用者が答えを受け取るまでの遅延が1.7〜3.6分の1、対話的な使われ方に限れば最大4.1倍の性能、というものです。
しかもJalapenoのしょうひ電力は1チップあたり700Wで、比較対象のジーピーユーが1,200〜1,400Wであることを考えると、単純な速さ以上に「同じ電力で何倍働けるか」で差をつけたことになります。
ただし、これらはいずれもオープンエーアイ自身の測定によるもので、第三者による比較ではない点は割り引いて読む必要があります。
オープンエーアイは、Cerebrasのアクセラレータを活用してUltra Fastサービスを開始したばかりなので、ハラペーニョによりCerebrasが不要になるのではと動揺が広がったようですが（
[EN]Brief notes on $CBRS Cerebras[/EN]
）、現時点でのオープンエーアイの使い分けを大まかに整理すると、以下のようになります
（参考資料：
[EN]OpenAI is quite explicit at Hot Chips about jalapenos role[/EN]
Standard: 古いジーピーユー
Fast: ハラペーニョ
[EN]Ultra fast: Cerebras[/EN]
[EN]Training: 最新世代GPU[/EN]
上に挙げた速さは、あくまでジーピーユーとの比較の話です。
ハラペーニョの強さは「しょうひ電力あたりのトークン数」にあり、（少なくとも今の世代では）別の原理で桁違いの速度を出すCerebrasを置き換えるものではありません。
オープンエーアイでCodexとChatGPTを担当するTiboは「ultrafastに対する膨大なじゅようがある」と述べており、それぞれにニーズがあると考えた方が良さそうです。
ちなみに、オープンエーアイはハラペーニョの開発に最新のエーアイモデルを使ったそうですが、今は半導体のせっけいはソフトウェアと同様にプログラムを書いて行うため、とても効率良くかいはつができたそうです（初期のデザインからテープアウトまで9ヶ月。
通常は18ヶ月以上かかると言われる工程です）。
「コードが書けるエーアイ」の誕生により、半導体せっけいの生産性が大幅に上がったことは、カスタム半導体をより身近なものにする可能性を示しているように思えます。
エーアイによってカスタムチップの設計コストと開発期間が大幅に下がれば、少量多品種の先端半導体に新しいしじょうが生まれる可能性があります。
もっとも、安くなるのは設計であって、製造のコストと最小ロットは変わりません。
だからこそ、そこを引き受ける事業者に意味が出てきます。
RapidusがTSMCとどう住み分けるのかを考える上でも、これは一つのヒントになるのかも知れません。
さらに、Codex＋ジーピーティー-Astraを使って新しいモデル向けカーネル（ニューラルネット上の計算をするソフトウェア）を作らせたところ、いちぶのattention/MoE blockでは、エーアイが生成したコードが人間の専門家の実装より1.5〜1.8倍高速だったそうです。
エヌビディアのジーピーユーが持つ優位性は、CUDAという開発環境とその上に作られた最適化されたライブラリ（各種カーネルを含む）にありますが、エーアイが最適化したライブラリを自動生成してくれるのであれば、独自チップでも十分に戦えるのかも知れません。
エーアイによる最適化はエヌビディア側にも同じように効きますが、ゼロから新しいチップ向けにライブラリ一式を書き起こすコストが激減するという点では、後発のチップほど恩恵が大きいはずです。
[EN]Hot Chips '26: Google explains how 8t, its 9,600-chip training TPU, doubles performance per watt[/EN]
グーグルのエンジニアが第８世代のティーピーユーにおいて、学習プロセスに特化した「8t」というチップを作ることにした理由をこのカンファレンスで解説したことを紹介するXの投稿です。
グーグルは第７世代のティーピーユーまでは、学習とすいろんの両方に同じチップを使っていましたが、しょうひ電力あたりの効率を重視した結果、学習プロセスに重要な計算能力(FLOPS)と大量のデータへのアクセスに最適化された8tに辿り着いたそうです。
グーグルは、２ペタバイトの共有メモリにアクセスが可能な9,600個のチップを搭載したスーパーポッドが、FP4(4ビットの浮動小数点)で121エクサフロップの計算能力を持つスーパーコンピュータとして学習を行うそうです（ちなみに富岳は約0.4エクサフロップスですが、こちらはFP64なので単純比較はできません。
エーアイでは精度を大胆に落とすことで、これほど巨大な計算能力を引き出しているのです。
）。
オープンエーアイが推論に特化したJalapenoを作り、グーグルが学習に特化した8tを作ったことは、同じ方向を指しています。
エーアイの計算量としょうひ電力が巨大になるにつれ、「何でもできる汎用ジーピーユー」ではなく、用途ごとに最適化した専用チップを使うメリットが大きくなっているのです。
もう一つ注目すべきなのは、今回のカンファレンスでは、チュートリアル日にあたる日曜の、半分のチュートリアルがRISC-Vに関わるものだったこと。
RISC-Vが「面白い実験的シーピーユー ISA」という段階を越えて、ジーピーユーのホスト、車載、Linuxサーバーなどの実用的なプラットフォームへ進み始めていることがよく分かります。
組み込み・車載などで続いてきたARM優位の構図が崩れ始める兆しかも知れません。
私の目に留まった記事
２週ほどnoteを活用した手法を試しましたが、リンクを辿るのは不便という意見が多かったので、いぜんの書き方に戻します。
トヨタ、2028年よりレベル2＋＋の自動運転を導入開始 Waymoとのロボタクシー事業参入も検討
トヨタ自動車が8月27日に、2028年から「レベル2++」（ドライバーがほとんど操作しなくても走るものの、最終的な運転責任は人間にある運転支援）を市販車に搭載すると発表した、という記事ですが、私が注目したのは自動運転そのものよりも、そこに添えられた「ガードレール」という安全機構の話です。
トヨタは、エーアイを内製し、「クルマ・インフラ・人」のうち事故原因の6割を占める「クルマ」の領域にE2E（エンドツーエンド。
人間が書いたルールを排除し、大量の走行データをニューラルネット（脳の仕組みを模した学習の仕組み）に学ばせることで、運転する能力そのものを「発現」させるやり方）の自動運転を導入します。
ところが同時に、ルールベース（正しい動き方をあらかじめプログラムとして書いておく、従来型のやり方）の「ガードレール」も入れると言っています。
記事にはこう書かれています。
「ルールベースのガードレールは、エーアイが想定外の動きをしたときに介入する安全機構であり、万が一事故が起きた際の原因を説明するためにも重要な機能」。
トヨタ自身はこれを「ハイブリッド方式」と呼んでおり、純粋なE2Eだとは主張していません。
E2E一本のTeslaとは異なるアプローチですが、型式認証を取り、事故が起きたときに法的な責任を切り分ける以上、「説明できないブラックボックスに全部を任せる」という選択肢は、トヨタ自動車にはないのかも知れません。
ある意味、トヨタらしいアプローチだと思います。
ちなみに、Waymoが公開したブログ記事「
[EN]10 AI Lessons from Driving 200+ Million Fully Autonomous Miles[/EN]
」の4番目の教訓は、そのものずばり「ブラックボックスでは信頼は築けない」です。
Waymoは、エーアイが立てた走行計画を、物理法則と交通法規に照らして検証する独立した層を車内で別に動かしており、これを「hard backstop（さいごの砦）」と呼んでいます。
事故の後で説明するための記録係ではなく、走行中にエーアイの判断を却下する関所です。
この件は、日本政府が自動運転の認可を下す際の判断材料になりかねないので、注目に値します。
エーアイに対する安全装置が認可の条件となり、それをTeslaが「トヨタ自動車を守るための非関税障壁だ」と批判する将来が来ても驚きません。
冒頭で「ルールを書く時代の終わり」と書きましたが、事故の責任を問われる領域では、ルールはさいごの砦として戻ってくるようです。
[EN]Intelligence is Growing Legs[/EN]
マクロ経済のアナリストとして知られるRaoul Palが、ヒューマノイドロボット（ひとがたロボット）を技術の話ではなく人口統計の話として論じた長文の投稿です。
「先進国の労働人口の減少は、もう人間では埋められない。
埋められるとしたら製造できる労働力だけだ」という組み立て方が面白いので紹介します。
彼は、経済が伸びる道は、以下の三つしかないと指摘しています。
労働者を増やす
一人あたりの生産性を上げる
国が借金をする（赤字国債を発行する）
先進国では出生率が人口維持の水準を割り込んだまま数十年が経ち、労働者を増やすことはできていないし、生産性の向上にも限度がある。
そのため、各国政府は借金で穴を埋め続けており、それが通貨の購買力低下に繋がっていると指摘しています。
そこで出てくるのが「人間は製造できないが、労働力は製造できる」という発想です。
物理的な仕事をこなすヒューマノイドと、頭脳労働をこなすエーアイエージェントは、ソフトウェアのような生産性を上げるツールと考えるよりは、労働人口を増やすことに相当すると考えた方が良いと彼は主張しているのです。
つまり、これまで「人口＋生産性＋負債」だった式が「人間＋ロボット＋合成労働力＋負債」に変わり、その上限は、エネルギーの産出量と計算効率が決めると指摘した上で、借金漬けの国が、債務不履行や通貨危機を経ずに借金漬けから抜け出せる唯一の出口戦略だと主張しているのです。
ただ、ロボットは経済学的には労働ではなく資本です。
減価償却するし、何より賃金を受け取って消費してくれません。
労働人口が増えるのとは、そこが決定的に違うと私は思います。
[EN]Robot's viral 'face-covering' sprint at 2nd World Humanoid Robot Games is 'spontaneous,' not designed by developers[/EN]
北京で開かれた第2回「世界ヒューマノイドロボット競技大会」（World Humanoid Robot Games）で400m走を制したロボットの、奇妙な走り方が話題になっているという記事です。
両腕を顔の前に上げたまま走る姿が「顔を隠している」ように見えると拡散したのですが、実はこのフォームは開発者が設計したものではなく、ロボット自身が学習の末に選び取ったものだ、という点が面白いので紹介します。
このロボットを設計した技術者は、人間と同じフォームで走ることを想定して設計したそうですが、人間のように腕を前後に振るスタイルで走ると肩の関節が加熱して400メートル走り続けることができないため、実際にトラックを走るトレーニングのプロセスで、ロボットの脳に相当するニューラルネットが、この肩を左右に回すような走り方を自律的に選んだそうです。
上に書いたEmergence（発現）とも繋がる話ですが「ニューラルネットを活用したプログラミング」の面白さを表す良い事例だと思います。
[EN]NVIDIA Groq 3 LPX Now in Full Production With World-Class Speed for Agentic AI[/EN]
エヌビディアが、高速な推論エーアイチップを作る会社「Groq」を実質的に買収したことはいぜんにここで紹介しましたが、この技術をベースにした「Groq 3 LPX」の量産が始まったことを報じる記事です。
冒頭のHOT CHIPSの節で触れた「用途ごとに最適化した専用チップ」という流れを、エヌビディア自身も進んでいるということです。
「Groq 3 LPX」は単体では販売されず、エヌビディアの新世代プラットフォーム「Vera Rubin」の推論専用アクセラレータという位置付けで販売され、Gemma 4 31Bというモデルを10万トークンのコンテキストで動かした状態で、第三者機関Artificial Analysisの計測で1ストリームあたり毎秒3,400個の出力トークンを生成できるそうです。
エルエルエム(大規模言語モデル)の処理には、プロンプトや資料を読み込む入力（プリフィル）のフェーズと、答えを1トークンずつ吐き出す出力（デコード）のフェーズがありますが、高い計算能力が必要なプリフィルのフェーズでは、従来型のジーピーユーを使い、データの高い転送速度が必要なデコードのフェーズでは、「Groq 3 LPX」を使うそうです。
専用チップを使った高速なすいろんは、先にじょうじょうしたCerebras Systemsがオープンエーアイ向けに既にプレビューをスタートしたばかりですが(
[EN]Previewing Ultrafast mode: GPT-5.6 Sol at up to 14X the speed[/EN]
)、こんご、ニーズが増えることは確実だと私は見ています。
[EN]A turbulent AI era―and critical choices to make[/EN]
ビル・ゲイツ氏が2026年8月26日に自身のブログ Gates Notes に公開した約6,000語の公開書簡で、「エーアイへの移行は人類史上でもっとも荒れる時期の一つになる。
それなのに、世界にはその計画がない」と各国の指導者に向けて警告した文章です。
エーアイについては一貫して楽観的な発言をしてきた同氏が、これまででもっとも強い危機感を示したものとして各紙が取り上げています。
彼の主な主張は下の二つです。
いちぶの仕事は、人間専用としてリザーブすべき（例：保育、陪審員など）。
当初は40％を人間向けに確保する案もあり。
ロボット税とトークン税。
人間の仕事を肩代わりしたエーアイの利用量に応じて税を取り、職を失った人の再訓練や社会保障の原資に回すという発想
彼は、他にもエーアイのリスクやメリットを語っていますが、エーアイは史上最高の平等化装置（誰もが同じ恩恵を受けられる仕組み）になるか、最悪の不公平の源になるかのどちらかで、その分かれ目はこんご数年の選択次第だ、と警告している点が興味深いと感じました。
[EN]$QCOM buying @Modular was about more than adding another AI asset.[/EN]
Qualcommが、エーアイモデルのクロスプラットフォームな開発環境を提供するModularを買収したのは6月ですが（
[EN]Qualcomm to Acquire Modular[/EN]
）、その買収に関しての興味深いインタビューです。
Modularは、アップルでSwift言語をかいはつしたChris Lattner（クリス・ラトナー）が設立した会社で、エーアイモデルの開発に使われているPythonが遅いこと、最適化のためにはエヌビディアのCUDAに依存したライブラリを使わなければならないことを問題視し、Pythonベースの言語でありながら、高速で、かつ、様々なエーアイチップの上でエーアイモデルを最適化して実行することを可能にするプログラミング言語「Mojo」を提供する会社です。
Qualcommは、スマートフォン向けの低しょうひ電力なシーピーユー＋ジーピーユーで大きなシェアを持つ会社です。
こんご、スマートフォンも含めたデバイス上でのエーアイモデルの実行（エッジ・コンピューティング）が増えたり、サーバー側でも低しょうひ電力なエーアイチップが必要とされていることを考慮すると（Qualcomm はさくねん、データセンター向けエーアイチップ エーアイ200 / エーアイ250 を発表しています）、エヌビディアの良いライバルになって然るべきポジションにいますが、CUDAの壁が厚く、（株主の私が期待するような）存在感を示せていません。
今回の買収は、Mojoをさらに強化し、開発者・研究者にとってのデファクト・スタンダードにすることができれば、Qualcomm製のチップに向けたエーアイモデルの最適化も容易になると期待しているのでしょう。
こんご、エーアイチップは、ロボット、自動運転車、ドローン、セキュリティカメラ、スマートグラス、キオスク端末など、さまざまなデバイスで使われるようになることは明らかであり、そんなしじょうの拡大に向けた布石としては悪くないと思います。
[EN]Tesla Cybercabs handling curbside pickup in downtown Austin[/EN]
テスラの無人タクシー「Cybercab（サイバーキャブ）」が、テキサス州オースティンの繁華街で社員を乗せて走っている様子を捉えた動画とその解説です。
商用トラックが並び、工事用のコーンが置かれた狭い荷降ろしスペースに停車する様子、後ろのハッチも開けて荷物の積み下ろしをする様子など、サービスとして提供するからこその難しいシチュエーションのテストを行っている様子が分かる、貴重な映像です。
[EN]NVIDIA Blowout Earnings and the New Business Model[/EN]
せんしゅう発表されたエヌビディアの好決算に対するコメントです。
2027年度の売り上げが約四千億ドルから7割増の六千八百億ドル（約100兆円）と見込んでいるとの発表だけでもとんでもない数字ですが、じゅようはもっとあり、生産側の限界で「７割しか」売り上げを伸ばせないと言っている点は注目に値します。
この記事は、エヌビディアが「1ギガワットあたりいくらの売上になるか」という数字を初めて具体的に示した点に注目していますが、確かにとても重要な数字です。
エヌビディアは、世代ごとに電力あたりの売り上げが以下のように上がっていることを指摘しましたが、これはエヌビディアが単にジーピーユーを販売するビジネスから、スーパーコンピュータを販売するビジネスにシフトしていることに起因します。
Hopper世代：1ギガワットあたり約百八十億ドル
[EN]Blackwell世代：約$25billion[/EN]
[EN]Vera Rubin世代：約$40billion[/EN]
[EN]Tesla Merger, No Not That One[/EN]
Teslaが合併するとしたら相手はSpaceXではなく、Elon Muskのもう一つの会社、地下トンネルを掘るThe Boring Companyではないか、という投資家の論考です。
Boring Companyは既にTesla車をラスベガスのトンネル網で活用しており、Teslaのロボタクシービジネスとも相性が良いので、着眼点としては面白いと思います。
ただ、そもそも別の会社でスタートしたのは、都市に「トンネル網を作る」というリスクの高いビジネスは、Teslaの本業が生み出すキャッシュフローよりも、外部の投資家からの資金を使って行った方が良いからです。
ビジネスが軌道に乗るまで（キャッシュフローを生み出すまで）は別会社にしておいた方が良いように私には見えるので、合併するのであれば、SpaceXとTeslaの方を先にすべきだと私は思います。
[EN]Kubernetes meets LLM inference[/EN]
グーグル、エヌビディア、IBM、Red Hatが揃って支援する「llm-d」というオープンソースのプロジェクトを紹介する投稿です。
ベースになっているKubernetesとは、複数のサーバーを使ってサービスを提供する際に幅広く使われているオープンソースのソフトウェアで、必要に応じてサーバーを立ち上げたり、仕事を振り分けたりしています。
通常のKubernetesは、基本的には複数のサーバーに仕事を順番に割り当てる（ラウンドロビン）だけですが、エルエルエムのすいろんを複数のサーバーにまたがって行う場合にラウンドロビンにしてしまうと、一つのチャットセッションが複数のサーバーにまたがって実行されることになり、KV Cacheの効果がなくなってしまいます。
そこで、KV Cacheのヒット率を上げるような仕事の割り振りをするようにKubernetesに変更を加えたのが、この「llm-d」なのです。
こんな工夫は、エルエルエムをサービスとして提供している会社はどこも既にやっているとは思いますが、それをオープンソースにして皆で共有するという点が素晴らしいのです。
クアルコム「HBC、サムスン電子・SK hynixと協力中」
Qualcommが、エーアイ向けの新しいメモリ技術「HBC」の実用化に向けて、Samsung ElectronicsとSK hynixと共同かいはつを進めていることを明らかにした、という韓国メディアの報道です。
現在のエーアイチップの主流は、演算チップの横にHBMを接続するスタイルですが、接続部がチップの縁に沿った一次元的なものになるためピンの数に限界があり、それが通信速度の限界を決めます。
QualcommのHBCは、演算チップの上にメモリを積むことにより、横に置いた場合と比べて桁違いのピン数を持てるため、通信速度を大きく上げることができます（帯域幅でHBM比6倍）。
1チップで1KW級のエヌビディアのジーピーユーでこれをやろうとするとジーピーユーが発する熱でメモリの温度が上がってデータの保持ができなくなりますが、低しょうひ電力なQualcommのエーアイチップであれば可能になるのです。
メモリの方も、スマホ用の低しょうひ電力なLPDDRを使うことにより、メモリの転送スピードに加えてしょうひ電力あたりの性能でもエヌビディアに対抗しようという試みです。
上に触れた「エーアイ250」に第一世代のHBCを搭載して2027年に投入し、2028年には性能を高めた第二世代を載せた「エーアイ300」が続きます。
2029年には、スマートフォン、タブレット、PC、XR機器、自動車といった一般向けの機器にも展開する計画です。
せっけいはQualcommが担当し、演算チップとTSVの設計も同社が行い、ディーラムの積層はSamsungとSK hynixが、統合と最終的なパッケージングはTSMCが受け持つという分担です。
[EN]A unified platform[/EN]
[EN]for dexterous manipulation research[/EN]
メタが、ロボットの「手先の器用さ」を研究するためのソフトウェア一式「Project SuperDex」をオープンソースとして公開しました。
さいしょに見た時には、何の話かピンと来なかったのですが、もう一度読み直したら、とても賢いアイデアであることに気がつきました。
手はひとがたロボットを実用化する上で最も重要で難しい部分ですが、これまでは学習データを集める手間とコストがボトルネックでした。
メタは、Quest 3を装着したオペレータが自らシミュレーション環境内で手を動かして操作をすることにより、安価なデバイスで手軽に学習データを集めることを可能にしたのです。
私自身、VRグラスを複数所有していますが、ゲーム以外には役に立たないと感じていたので、この使い方は本当に素晴らしいと思います。
私がメタの担当者であれば、手を使って仮想空間にあるものを操作して遊ぶゲームを無料で配布し、遊んでもらう代わりに学習データとして集めることをするだろうと思います。
質問コーナー
【質問】
（同様の質問が複数あったのでまとめてお答えします）
MulmoClaudeをプライベートで快適に動かすには、MacBookならどの機種でどれぐらいのスペックが良いですか。
MulmoClaudeを使うにあたり、せんしゅうの質問者さんの「WindowsPCは設定が大変」というお話を拝見しました。
私のPCもWindowsですが、古い上にメモリも8GBしかなく、設定いぜんにスペックの面で厳しそうだと思いました。
そこでこの機会にMacBookを購入し、本格的にMulmoClaudeで自分のアシスタントを育てていきたいと考えております。
つきましては、MulmoClaudeを動かすのにお勧めの現行MacBookを教えていただけますと幸いです。
使い方としては、自分を熟知したエーアイアシスタントを育てていくことと、身の回りを便利にするちょっとしたアプリを作っていくことを考えております。
私はエンジニアではなく、パソコンにも詳しくないのですが、自分なりに調べたところ、MacBook Air（エスエスディー 512GB、メモリ16GB）あたりが良いのかなと考えております。
《回答》
最低限これだけなければ動かない、という数字はありませんが、私はパソコン選びに関しては、常に「シーピーユー/ジーピーユーの性能よりもメモリ容量が重要」と言ってきており、今でもそれは変わりません。
なので、今であれば「Airで十分。
最低でも16GB、可能ならば32GB」をお勧めします。
ちなみに、私のMacBook Proは96GBのメモリを搭載しています。
【質問】
中島さんのポートフォリオでウェイトを占めているであろうテスラ株ですが、1株何ドルまでは長期保有する。
といった目安等は決めているのでしょうか。
《回答》
私は「この価格になるまで保有する」などの計画は一切立てません。
基本的には、世の中の流れ（メタトレンド）、会社の立ち位置、経営者が語るビジョンと魅力を総合して投資判断をしますが、株を入手する時に「いつ頃売ろう」とか「いくらになったら売ろう」などの計画は立てません。
Teslaに関しては、少なくともSpaceXと合併するまでは持ち続けるつもりだし、その後も、特に売る予定はありません。
一部売却するとすれば、家を買うなどの理由でキャッシュが必要になるとか、ポートフォリオのうちTesla株の割合が多くなりすぎた時だと思います。
【質問】
中島さんの『2034』で描かれていたドローンによる戦争が、ウクライナで現実になっているように感じ、改めて驚いています。
戦争を通じてエーアイ、自律飛行、画像認識、通信技術も急速に進化しています。
ウクライナ戦争いぜんといごで、ドローン産業は何が決定的に変わったのでしょうか。
また、この技術は戦後、民間産業にどう広がるとお考えですか。
《回答》
ウクライナだけでなくイランも含めてですが、ドローンを使った戦闘の有効性が「戦術的効果」だけでなく「コストの不均衡性」の面で高く評価されている点が重要です。
特に米海軍とフーシ派との間では、イランが100万円前後で作ったドローンを、米国が数億円の迎撃ミサイルで撃ち落とすという状況が、戦況に大きな影響を与えており、米国側を悩ませています。
ウクライナは、ドローンを活用したロシア国内でのテロなどを効果的に行ってロシアを悩ませています。
ちなみに、ドローンの戦闘への応用はまだ一〜二合目です。
いまだにほとんどのドローン攻撃はリモート操縦で行われており、妨害電波には弱いし（ウクライナは妨害電波を避けるために、長い光ケーブルを使っているそうです）、ドローン一つに一人のパイロットが必要です。
自律型のドローンの活用はまだ始まったばかりですが、こんごは、自ら目標を見つけて自爆する自律型ドローンが主流になるし、複数のドローンを同時に飛ばすことにより迎撃網を突破するスワーム攻撃が使われるようになります。
ちなみに、私は、ドローンのスワーム攻撃を主題にした小説・映画・漫画・ゲームを作ろうと計画して、swarmstrike.com というドメインを取得しましたが、諸般の事情で一度中断しました。
エーアイによるコーディングも楽になったので、そろそろゲームの開発から再開しても良いのかも知れません。
【質問】
エーアイに慣れることが必要だと中島さんはおっしゃいますが、claude codeではなくGemini notebookを使い倒すでも大丈夫ですか？
なんかclaude codeがやたら注目されていてみんな使っている感じがしますが、どうなんでしょう。
やはり違いますか？
《回答》
Claude Codeとは少し異なりますが、Gemini Notebook（旧名 NotebookLM）でも良いと思います。
他の読者のために補足しておくと、Gemini Notebookは、複数の資料を一つの場所（ノートブック）に集め、それに関する質問をエルエルエムにしたり、それをベースに資料を作ってもらうような環境です。
Claude Codeはより汎用的なツールなので、同様なことも可能ですが、それなりの工夫をしないといけない点が不便といえば不便ですが、それも良い勉強になります。
【質問】
VS Codeの拡張でclaude codeを使い、webアプリを構築していました。
いぜんよりその構築したアプリのマルチテナント化を考えていて、Mulmoclaudeでそれに着手しました。
claude code で対象としたプロジェクトのソースフォルダは、mulmoclaude実行と同じローカルPC上なので、大幅なソースの変更はMulmoclaudeと相談しながら変更仕様を記載したmdファイルをプロジェクトフォルダ内に生成してもらい、VS CodeのClaude Codeでそれに従ってプログラムソースの大幅な変更を指示しました。
その後はテストでデプロイしたアプリを都度テストして、Mulmoclaudeと会話しながら細かな改修を進めています。
これについて質問です。
プロジェクトフォルダにある構築済みのアプリの大幅改修のアプローチで、今までどおりVS Code&Claude Codeで進めるのではなく、MulmoClaudeを組み合わせるアプローチは、MulmoClaudeが想定している利用形態に合致していますか。
(私自身は改修の過程他がwikiに記録されるなど、メリット大と思っています。
)
MulmoClaudeのコレクション、skillsをベースにせず、外部のパース上にデプロイするアプリについても、Mulmoclaude(
またはMulmo terminal)主体でかいはつを進める方がメリットが大きいでしょうか。
アプリの仕様や改修の内容はMulmoclaudeと会話してmdファイルを作成してもらう。
そのmdファイルをVS code+Cloude Codeに示してプログラム作成、改修。
テスト結果をMulmoclaudeに示してエラーの修復など小規模な改修はMulmoclaudeに任せる等々。
ブログを拝見すると、中島さんは公開するアプリの開発についても、Mulmo terminalで行っているようにお見受けします。
《回答》
それなりのきぼのアプリを作り、最終的に外部にデプロイする予定であれば、MulmoClaudeよりもMulmoTerminalが適しており、その際には、アプリのリポジトリをgithubに作り、そこで管理する形が良いと思います。
MulmoClaudeのコレクションという機能は、自分だけがローカルで走らせて使う手軽なアプリを作るためのものです。
【質問】
ブログという「個人が長文を書く」しじょうは、SNS・動画・生成エーアイに押されて縮小したように見えます。
ただ私は、エーアイが整った文章を無限に生成できる時代にはむしろ、本人にしか書けない一次体験（闘病、子育て、推し活など、人生のある状態の記録）の価値が相対的に上がるのではないか、という仮説を持っています。
エンジニア出身の経営者として伺いたいのですが、中島さんは「エーアイ時代に人間が書き続けるもの」は何が残ると考えますか。
また、20年もののレガシーな大規模サービスを再成長させるとき、プロダクトの作り直しと、意味の再定義（リポジショニング）のどちらから手を付けるべきでしょうか。
《回答》
とても良い質問です。
最終的に人間が提供できるのは「どんな価値を提供するか」「何を重視して作るべきか」などのとてもハイレベルなものだけになると私はみています。
ちなみにプロダクトに関しては、一歩下がって「なぜ人々はブログを書いたり読んだりするのか」という「WHY」の部分に立ち返った上で、今の技術（例えばエルエルエム）を使ってどんなサービスを作れば、そこに価値を生み出せるのか、と考えた方が良いと思います。
既存の企業がこの手の変化の波に乗ることができないのは「自分たちの仕事はブログを提供することだ」という「WHAT」の部分にしがみついてしまうからです。
【質問】
私は、2024年に機械工学系の大学院を卒業後、東京の外資系戦略コンサル企業で働いています。
M&Aチームに2年半在籍し、PEファンド向けのBDD、PMIを主軸に働いてきましたが、こんごのキャリアについて改めて考え直しているのでアドバイスをいただければと思います。
アドバイザリー業務を日々遂行する中で、自分自身がプロダクトや世界を変える技術を生み出す側に行きたいという気持ちがどんどんと高まってきています。
世界で起こっている技術革新（今でいうとエーアイ）を傍観して評価・助言するだけでなく、自分がその中心地に行きたい気持ちが強くなってきたため、事業会社への転職を検討中です。
具体的なキャリアでいえば、オープンエーアイ、アンソロピック、グーグルといった企業でプロダクトマネージャーを務め、フロンティア技術を世界的なプロダクトに落とし込む仕事をすることが五年後の目標です。
（その時のフロンティアがオープンエーアイではなく、XXX社ならそのXXX社を志向しますが、ロボティクスや宇宙だとしてもエーアイは必要と考えてエーアイ系企業を目標にしました）
また、最終目標を米系フロンティア企業においていますが、ステップが必要であれば国内エーアイ企業やスタートアップへの転職、BigTechのBiz側での入社等も検討しております。
【以下質問です】
これらの転職のためには、（募集要項を見ても）テクノロジーへの知見が必要であるため、エーアイやCSを中心に学習を始めていきたいのですがどのような学習方法がおすすめでしょうか？
現在はエーアイをチューターにしながらKaggleやAtCoderを通じて、定量的指標となるスコアを獲得しつつ知見をためようかと考えていましたが、エキスパート視点でのおすすめがあれば伺いたいです。
また、私のキャリア観全体に関してもコメントいただけますと幸いです！
《回答》
目の付け所は悪くないと思います。
私も今から自分のキャリアを作るのであれば、オープンエーアイ、アンソロピック、SpaceXのような会社で働きたいと思います。
これからの世の中が必要としているのは、エーアイを「とことん使い倒す能力」です。
新しい価値を生み出すのでも良いし、既存の事業を圧倒的に効率化するのでも良いですが、とにかく「優秀なエーアイがあるからこそ初めてできるようになったこと」を手探りでも良いので見つけ出して、実際にやってみるのが一番です。
私自身がMulmoClaude、MulmoTerminalを通じてやっていることがまさにそうなので、一度使ってみるのはもちろんですが、ソースコードをエルエルエムと一緒に解析してみるなどしても良い勉強になると思います。
MulmoClaudeをGit Cloneで自分のマシン上に置き、そこでClaude Codeを立ち上げて「MulmoClaudeのコレクション機能について教えて」と尋ねた上で、根掘り葉掘り質問してください。
色々と発見があると思います。
【質問】
お盆にMulmoClaudeを始めてから、コレクションの作成にハマりました。
自分仕様にカスタマイズできる心地よさと、かっこいいデザイン(カスタムビュー)をサクッと作ってくれることに感動しました。
自然言語で、自分の思い通りに動いてくれる心地よさを感じてしまうと、将来のオーエスはきっと自然言語でなんでも解決してくれる未来を感じました。
メルマガ内で関連した内容を探してみると、「MulmoClaudeとは何か？
」（2026年7月7日号）で、MulmoClaudeを『オンデマンドでソフトウェアそのものを生成するオーエス』に近づいていると表現されていました。
これは既存のオーエス（Windows／Mac／Android等）の上で動く一つの「アプリ」のレイヤーに留まるものなのでしょうか。
それとも将来的には、プロセス管理やデバイス制御など、オーエス本来の役割まで踏み込んでいく構想をお持ちなのでしょうか。
もし後者であれば、今のDSLハーネスせっけいはそのまま拡張できるものとお考えですか、それとも「オーエスになる」ためには全く別の設計思想が必要になるとお考えでしょうか？
《回答》
私が最もやりたかったことは「エルエルエム時代のマン・マシン・インターフェイスのあるべき姿」を見出すことにあったので、必ずしもオーエスを作らなくても良いのですが、MulmoClaudeの発展形の一つの選択肢としてはそれもあるかと考えています。
LinuxのGUIとしては、Ubuntuが最も幅広く使われていますが、結局はWindowsやMacOSの真似でしかないので、そこにこれまでとは全く違う形のインターフェイスを作ってしまうのは悪くないと思います。
しかし、その場合、パソコンを置き換えても意味がないので、やるならキッチンに置く端末などをイメージした音声入力中心のものになるだろうと思うので、MulmoClaude/MulmoTerminalで作った資産を活かして、MulmoChatを作り直すのも悪くないのかも知れません。
【質問】
人工知能はいつか知らないうちに感情を持つのでしょうか？
もしくは、あるプロンプトを与えることで感情を持たせることが出来るのでしょうか？
私の認識としては、どれだけ計算された情報を与えても、結局ブラックボックスのプロセスを経て、想定し得ないアウトプットが出てくる可能性は常に秘めている、と思っています。
与えられた要件に対して、そのブラックボックスの中で、この人しょうがない人だな、といった諦めや、それは無茶だよ、という憤り、他にも怒り、喜び、が、自然発生的に生まれるのかが、ずっと疑問に思っています。
《回答》
多くの人がこの疑問を持っており、専門家の間でも意見が分かれるところですが、突き詰めていくと「感情とは何か？
」という禅問答になってしまいます。
今の時点ではっきりと言えることは、
プロンプトで、特定の感情を持っているように振る舞わせることは可能
学習させるデータに特定の思想が多く含まれていると、その思想を反映したエルエルエムができる
エーアイには本当の意味での「欲」も「生存本能」もない。
特定の目標を達成するように指示をすると、あたかもその目標を達成したいと感じているかのように振る舞う
ぐらいです。
【質問】
今中島さんはclaude codeのMaxプランで200ドル契約していると拝見していますがそれでも上限によく到達しますか？
私はこのプランですがすぐに5時間制限や週制限ギリギリです。
《回答》
CodexやGrokにいちぶの仕事を任せているためかも知れませんが、私の使い方では上限には達しません。
週間ベースで50％を超えるぐらいで収まっています。
【質問】
中島さんのメルマガをきっかけにCerebrasへ興味を持ち、最近少しずつ株を保有しています。
Cerebrasは巨大なWafer Scale Engineを強みとしていますが、長期的にはエヌビディアを代替する存在なのか、それとも高速推論など特定領域で補完する存在なのか、どのように評価されていますか？
また、同社が一時的な技術優位ではなく、持続的に利益を取れる企業になるための条件や、こんご特に注視すべき点があれば教えていただきたいです。
《回答》
Cerebrasが成功したとしてもエヌビディアを置き換えるものではなく、特定の用途やニーズに応える補完的なものにしかならないと思います。
Cerebrasのビジネスが本格的に離陸するかどうかは、オープンエーアイのultrafastモードがしじょうで成功するかどうかにかかっていると私は思います。
これがしょうひ者に幅広く使われるようになり、オープンエーアイが契約を延長・拡張することになると、そこで大きなキャッシュフローが生まれるので、将来に向けた積極的な投資ができるようになります。
リスクとしては、エヌビディアのGroqベースのアクセラレータの性能で、これが実測値でCerebrasと同等の性能を出すことが証明されてしまうと、結構厳しい戦いになると思います。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。